All right.
Thank you all for coming.
I'm Craig.
I work in the Google Enterprise
team on the Cloud Platform.
And what I want to spend
a bit of time telling
you about today is
some of the things
that we've announced
recently and some
of the new advances that we feel
will be leading the industry
over the next months
in the area of Cloud.
So another quote from
Snapchat, they just
had a great release yesterday
of a video product which
is powered by the
Cloud Platform.
So you can just hold your
finger down and video chat
to someone for the period
that you're doing that.
So still very much
in the original idea
of ephemeral conversation
based around pictures,
but now much more
throughput, much more
capacity required Easy to
do on the Cloud Platform.
They've got about
25 engineers now.
They have a couple people who
do a little bit of op stuff
every now and then.
But in general, by
picking Google App Engine,
they can have the developers
focus on new features.
You don't have to worry
about provisioning servers,
load balances, all the stuff
[? Riff ?] mentioned before.
It's very easy.
You write code.
You give it to us to run.
We have a team of site
reliability engineers
who look after everything
for the platform,
so all you have to think about
is writing your own code.
Even though we've got
this, we believe at Google
that Cloud is still too hard.
There's two main areas
that we're attacking.
The first one is the
complexity of pricing.
So if you've used Cloud before,
you're familiar with the idea.
You pay a little bit
for your service.
You pay a little
bit for your disks.
You pay a little bit
for your networking.
All together,
you'll get something
that is a lot cheaper than doing
things the traditional way,
but you quite often need to have
a Ph.D. In statistics to figure
out pricing models and what
the best thing to do is.
Second area is
the current clouds
force you to make
trade offs in decision.
So if you've chosen
to adopt a platform,
you might find that
you outgrow that.
And a number of famous
apps-- Twitter, for example,
built on Ruby on
Rails-- got to a point
where you were seeing the whale
all the time because they just
couldn't handle the load.
They had to stop.
That had to re-engineer.
And they've got a really
great service today,
but they had to bring on a
completely different team
in order to be able to do that.
We think you should be
able to start here and get
to here without having to
change anything along the way.
And some announcements that
we've made talk about that.
So first of all,
the price of Cloud
has fallen over
the last few years,
but the price of hardware has
fallen at a far greater rate.
So when you think about
Moore's law, which
says that compute power
should double every 18 months,
it goes to say that
the price of running
a standard unit
of compute should
halve about every 18 months.
So we've done two
things in order
to equalize the market around
this idea of Moore's law.
First is the on demand
price reductions,
and second is an
innovative new model
for pricing around
sustained use.
So with on demand
price reductions,
we've dropped the price 32%.
All the other vendors
dropped their price
to match pretty much the next
day, but only on the things
that they compete with.
So we're really
setting the market
to trend for where
prices should be.
So that goes across
every compute thing
we run, all regions,
all sizes, all classes.
Cloud storage, other
vendors dropped their price
not quite as ambitiously
as this, but now
everything you
store on the Cloud--
it was previously around
7 or 8 cents a gigabyte,
and you'd have tiering
down to about $0.05-- we've
dropped that to a flat
2.6 cents per gigabyte.
I don't think you
can buy hard drives
for that price on
the common market.
If you want what we call
durable reduced availability,
we back it up in a small
number of data centers,
it's now only 2 cents per
gigabyte rather than 2.6 cents
So great for archive data.
We have a big data
product called BigQuery.
And we probably won't have
time to talk about it today,
but as it's been
mentioned, it lets
you query across all
of the information
that you might have.
Petabyte scale, every event
that's ever been generated,
every edit in Wikipedia,
you can do a query
over that in 5 or 10
seconds, something
that traditional
databases can't do.
It was previously $35.00
per terabyte processed.
We want to democratize
this capability
that we use
internally at Google.
We want to make it
available to everybody.
So the price has been dropped
to $5.00 per terabyte.
And at the end,
we'll have a chat
about how we can
give you some credit
to get involved with this.
We have great
opportunities for if you
outgrow the need for this.
If you need to do
streaming stuff, probably
not the initial scale, but you
can purchase reserve capacity
for BigQuery.
And effectively, it'll
cost you four times as much
to do what you do on
BigQuery with industry
pricing for other
vendors that don't even
let you perform it as quickly.
So to recap, end
of March we reset
the pricing on the market.
We found that a number other
vendors made several cuts,
but they're really just paying
lip service to the idea.
Google have been running
this kind of scale
internally for 15
years and we want
to make this
available to everyone.
We want to make it available
to all developers who
want to come along
and use our platform.
That was the original
promise of the Cloud,
is you could say well, I
want some of this today
and I want some
of that tomorrow,
and you can balance things.
But the model that
got adopted was well,
I've got to buy a
reservation and it'll
grant me the right to
run this at this price.
And it really doesn't
go along with what
we thought the
original model was.
This is what I talked about
before about pricing models.
You say well, if we just
use it, we'll pay this much.
But we can buy reservations
which allow different things
and the idea of having
to model your pricing,
and then well that doesn't
really go with well,
I don't know what I
need to use today.
And if I'm lucky, then I
might have this problem.
Or if I want to fail fast
and try a lot of things,
then that what do I do?
Is it worth taking
the upfront discount
in order to be able to
potentially succeed over time?
So we think what you should get
is the best price, regardless.
No upfront payments, no
lock in, no complexity.
So what we've launched is
sustained use discounts
on our pricing.
So that was our old
on demand, right.
You'd pay 10.5 cents an hour.
So let's say 32% drop
to start with that.
That's our new on demand rate.
And the more you use,
the less you pay.
And so overall, it averages
out at the same rate
that other people
offer reservations.
But if you use 100%
of a month-- so
if you run a server full time
over the course of the month--
the rate is effectively 20%
lower than it was beforehand.
So that works out
to a 53% price drop
if you're using
sustained compute
over the course of that month.
So that's just a
little recap of what
we've done to the
pricing in the industry.
We hope that will help you
realize the initial promise
of cloud computing, which
is predictable low pricing
and aligned with Moore's law.
But Cloud's still too hard.
You have to make tradeoffs
to work around the weaknesses
and limitations that
Cloud vendors offer.
You have to choose
between a quick time
to market, like we
mentioned with Twitter
before, or scalability.
You have to choose
between flexibility
or automatic management,
so the scales
that Alex was talking about
before between a managed
service and a lower
level compute service.
And when you're
doing big data, you
have to choose
between do you want
to be able to query in
a lot of information,
or do you want to be able
to access it in real time?
And what we're
doing here at Google
is changing the or to the
and in all of these cases.
And let's just quickly talk you
through what we're doing here.
Developer productivity,
we don't want
you to have to choose between
time to market and scale.
We want you to be able to
use the tools that you love.
do deployments quickly.
We want you just to be
able to push code to us,
and then we'll worry
about everything else.
We want to be able
to offer an ability
to look across the logs for
all the applications you're
running, find and fix
errors in production
quickly, let you get out
there, let you put test
environments up, and
more importantly,
let you see when
things are going
wrong in the real production
environment, and change them.
Now I'll try my little demo.
The easiest way to do
this might actually
be just to look at the screen.
If I can-- nope.
So I've come up with a
completely original idea
for a mobile
application which is
in no way derivative
of anything whatsoever.
[LAUGHTER]
So I've got my little app
running in production.
And the great news is,
I'm not very good at it.
You're welcome to give it
a go and say, oop, one.
All right.
So see here, I probably
don't have a very high score.
So I go and look at
the high score table
and see that my score of one
is being registered, obviously.
Turns out that my
broken demo possibly
isn't as broken as
I hoped it would be.
But what we did is actually
introduced a bug in this
that we want to demonstrate.
So all of the logs generated
by this application
are available here
in our log console.
And if we have a look at
this one, for example,
you can see here that
there's an error message.
It says there was an error
uploading a high score.
And so, in the
action of refactoring
our code and we've
made a change,
we pushed it into production,
and we've actually
got an error.
And what you can do now
is you can click through
from the production log
console to the actual source
repository.
So I can come in
here and I can see
the code that's in the Git
repository that we provide.
And you could also
link this to GitHub
if you're using that
for collaboration.
And we can see the error that's
generated here is to say,
if the user is not an admin,
then throw an exception.
And we obviously want everyone
to be able to participate.
So what we can do is just go
into the Edit button there,
and we can actually
make changes to this.
So we don't need
that line of code.
So what I'll do is
comment that out.
Now that might be
something that you're
familiar with doing
if you're a developer,
is logging onto a machine.
And then what you
obviously do is
you're setting up a situation.
Well, it's out of sync now.
I've made a change and
it's not in my repository.
What this is actually
doing is this
is committing code
to our repository.
And this gives me a
chance to introduce
our new build test
pipeline to you.
So under Cloud Development
in that Cloud Console,
we have a connected
Git repository.
And this app's
written in Java and it
uses the Maven build system.
So that fix that
I've just committed,
that's actually being sent off
to a virtual machine running
at Google, which is
connected to your account.
It's built, so it's
pulling that code down.
It's compiling it for you.
It runs all your unit tests.
You see that's just gone past.
And then it's deploying it.
So this is exactly
the same pipeline
that your developer would use
if it were developing locally
on their machine.
They'd commit a
change, they'd push it,
and then it would deploy.
And that's available for
you to do collaboratively
through the web.
For any of these changes,
you can go through
and look at the differences.
So that one they changed the
logo, so it's not too exciting.
But if I go back to one with
some source-- so previously,
we had a unit test here.
The unit test, if we
do a longer example,
will show you that
making that change
actually breaks the unit test.
So you can go through
and change that as well.
And so now, having
made that change
and changed the source
for that function,
it will let you save
your high scores.
Seeing as I can't
get much past one,
that's probably not
worth me trying.
But there's an example of
some of the devops tooling
that we've made available in
the Google Cloud Platform.
So flexibility and management,
Alex touched on this before.
You have the choice
to run anything
you want if you run it
on a traditional server,
or you have the
choice to write code
for App Engine, which lets
us scale it very quickly,
make it available through the
log viewer and all the things
you just saw there.
We want to make that
available to everyone
coming from both ends of
the problem of serving.
So we've made available
managed virtual machines.
And the idea here
is that it lets
you use the flexibility
of Compute Engine,
but still have the
productivity of being able just
to write code and push it to us.
So what you can do-- I don't
have time to give you a demo
now-- but you can take
a module of your code
and say I want to
run this on a VM
rather than running
it in App Engine.
And what that does
is it lets you
install other software on there.
So with App Engine,
for example--
sorry if I'm going
too deep for people,
but you can't use module.
So if you have some
PHP code and you
want to install an extension
to PHP that's written in C,
we don't let you run
arbitrary native code.
But if you want to
use a VM to do this,
you can say just
install this module.
So a great example
of this is we have
a demo which you can
look online the URL
at the end, which
is a Sudoku solver.
And it uses a computer
graphics library.
So you can point a
camera at a Sudoku,
and then it uses a C++ library
to do image recognition of that
Sudoku, and then
read the numbers,
feed that back into
a python algorithm,
and then give you
the solved Sudoku.
So that lets you have
high availability.
We look after those machines.
We have them come and
go as they need to.
We instantiate them.
They're managed
through the console.
The logs go into the same
place that you saw before.
We will make sure that
they're security patched.
So we will take your code,
deploy it onto those machines,
and then manage
them as necessary.
So this is the slides that
Alex started presenting before.
We want to be able
to go as a spectrum.
And you can't quite see the
gray boxes with the projector,
unfortunately, but
at the lowest level
you have Compute
Engine, which is
just you have to look
after your own servers.
A level up there, we
offer a tool called
Replica Pools, where you can
say, I have a bunch of servers
that all do the same thing.
And I'm just going to say as
long as they respond this way,
then they're healthy.
And so you can just
take your server image
and expose an endpoint
to say I'm healthy.
And then if they
stop being healthy,
Google will automatically
terminate them
and turn on another one.
Managed VMs, I just mentioned,
sits on top of that.
And then these traditional
App Engine managed runtimes.
So we're really
trying to make this
a spectrum between
flexibility and agility
where you can choose
where you want to be.
And that's not a choice
you have to make initially.
You can say upfront today,
App Engine is great for me,
but then if you
want to do things
that it doesn't allow you to
do, we'd call it breaking glass.
And you could move further
down the stack and introduce
lower level components
over time, as you need.
And it's as easy as just
pushing-- again, using
either Git or gcloud SDK
to say this is my app.
I want to update it.
Send it to the Cloud.
So under the hood, I'll just
give you a quick overview.
A load balancer will
turn on the machines,
run your application survey,
any third party libraries
that you specify and the code
that's in your repository.
We look after everything
else over here,
so monitoring and
health checking.
If you want to use
services like Task Queues,
Memcache, and sitting on top
of our Cloud, Cloud Datastore.
You don't have to
worry about anything
other than your own
code and specifying
if you want to use any
third party libraries.
Those parts in yellow
are the only things
that you need to provide.
Google will manage
all the rest for you.
Big data, real time.
With BigQuery, we can ingest
100,000 rows per second.
So this is obviously
of interest to people
who are doing
hardware start ups.
So if you're doing
sensor information,
we have a partner
in Seattle who've
got electricity
meters in 40,000 homes
that once a minute
send a ping of usage
back to the electric company.
And it lets them graph
outages on a map.
So they can see the power's
gone offline in these areas,
or they can predict problems.
So there's all sorts of
interesting problems.
You don't have to
wait until tomorrow I
can look at yesterday's
information.
You can see that in real time.
You can go back
and say, what was
the state of my
data six hours ago?
You can say, how
have things changed?
So we have some great
visualization partners
which help you look at this.
There's just one more
slide there on things
that we think are really
driving the growth in big data.
Census, low cost of ingestion,
new programming models that
will let you do parallel
data processing, and being
able to use open
source software,
and being able to pay as
you use with the Cloud.
Today, when you're
looking at a new business,
you should say every single
piece of information I ever
collect, every event a user
generates on my app, everything
that happens on
my mobile website,
I'm going to store that.
Big data doesn't necessarily
mean big in the small company,
it might just mean everything.
Store every single
piece of information,
every bit of
intelligence you can.
Then later on, you might
think all right, well, I
can think of insights.
I can think of a
way to track users
went through this
particular flow.
What percentage of
people bought a product
after having looked
at this page?
What percentage of
people dropped off
after getting to a point?
How many people played one
level of Fluttery Bird and then
gave up because it was too hard?
All that kind of
insight you can get.
And you don't need to
think about it today.
You can store that and
then query it in real time
whenever you need.
So that's me.
Thank you very much.
I just want to announce
my colleague, [INAUDIBLE]
down the back who's
going to give us a wave.
If you're interested in
$20,000 worth of credit
for use of the Google
Cloud Platform,
we have a pack for startups.
Qualification is
based on-- basically
for new companies who have
not been around too long
and have not taken
too much funding.
So if you're interested in
finding out if you're eligible,
he'll be around on the
break to have a chat.
Are we all right for
questions, or how are we for--